he was to accept Islam argument saying
what would it mean to you
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah well one question
to your mom if argument's sake if he was
to accept Islam argument saying what
would it mean to you like just
hypothetically if he was cool yeah I
think that I think the answer to that
question will change as I continue on
this path and learn more but right now
today I would be supportive because I
love him and I want what's best for him
and if he's living a you know the right
life like a really walking a straight
path and doing the right things and
staying away from you know gambling and
drugs and alcohol and all the things I
you know I would be supportive but it
would make me sad because for me you
know my Christianity is becoming such a
big part of my life that it's something
I want to share with him and I want to
experience it with him as a family and
also just you know the culture really
you know people say people will go back
hundreds of years and tell me I know
Sicily yeah you know the Moors are there
or whatever that I'm just talking about
like the last few generations of my
family the last four or five generations
was just like Italians Italian you know
a couple Generations ago they moved to
America so we're just a sicilian
Catholic you know uh rituals and
holidays that we celebrate that really
are important and for me they're in my
DNA and I would feel like he would be
then disconnected from his ancestors and
that matters to me because culture you
know it doesn't matter as much as God
but it does matter and I think it's
really good for Humanity for us to have
you know culture and traditions so I
would struggle it would hurt me but not
enough to put a rift between us like I
will let nothing come between us yeah
nice understandable yeah my mom's always
been supportive of me even my even
though when my dad was really hostile my
mom's always been there like she's
disappointed me yeah so yeah and I don't
think his dad would be hostile either
you know I think his dad would also be
kind of like how I am you know maybe it
would less so but he would he would you
know you've got to make sure you know I
just I would have to explain it
obviously you know yeah yeah and I'm
glad I just hope that you'll explore as
you're exploring this you know you'll
explore you know other avenues and
really find the one that's right for you
and when you're 19 maybe you are old
enough to you you aren't old enough but
maybe you will come to conclusions now
but this is a journey that may take a
while too it takes like you you've only
been you know within me 10 years in half
years I looked into three and a half
years like Bible Islam different like is
is a is a journey yeah yeah and it's a
beautiful journey I think working no
matter what you end up believing again I
think that these just may be different
paths to the same place
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sadakhajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the Charlotte American reward
click the link and donate what you can